in that private yes I bet shaky with the
drugs
lieutenant play I'm agent Norman Jayden
from the FBI based on what we've seen
looks like the work of the aah yeah
maybe the killer's car things gonna be
here I hate you is there something else
you wanted to tell me Ethan
oh yeah well we tell him about it
no no you know I didn't mean what I said
before I was just saying
how we going red my name is Ola shut
Jason skies watch y'all Thanks
I don't know that didn't make sense I
should be creative
anyway we were in the park and we keep
ending up in the same street whenever
we're with it Shawn
I don't know what this is place maybe
it's tied to something Charlie where
Shawn I don't know no I don't believe it
I couldn't have you couldn't have what I
just can't remember a thing
I heard all the hell did I get here
where and Shawn job John okay only
two-time as your week in treating your
breath Oh what is going on I don't
remember that uh uh action oh my gosh ah
John John Shawn Shawn where are you yeah
well this is not good I thought he's I
need to think anything think he's back
back still here but where's Shawn uh the
house must have gone back to the house
how do we go back enough he's not here
all right I get to believe then Shawn
where's uh uh waited a little boy gah
keep running
holy [ __ ] is back it's not gonna be here
oh no it is Xiang Akina oh no poor gaya
two sons in one three months or [ __ ]
like that
[Music]
you poor guy and he has a recommend
enzyme
[Music]
at its sad-eyed some sad [ __ ] ah we're
back today I don't know his name that's
a little scarce go there I wonder what
that's all about is it me who only wants
to pick their nose that's all I can
think of no but please continue
[Music]
I always like how they have so many
stuff going on like so many characters
in one scene I don't know it's pretty
cool all right take long it's gonna take
long
no he should be finished soon yeah
that's okay cool what can I do about it
oh yeah you can play where they re
because why not
it probably looks really normal as
played with the baseball really you can
literally do anything but this is all
they come up with a ball through the
wall ha ha ha ha ha hello how I
entertain you
he's like what the [ __ ] is he doing
I want what he's been smoking can I do
that I got a high score even yeah I have
is that it Wow he sounded a lot of time
holy [ __ ] he really loves his game huh I
think I have nuts it for now pretty cool
huh pretty cool
all righty then
let's wiggle our channel in the bet fell
ball comfortable and their arm cross
there we go finally Jesus Kai I'm off
Shirley now look at the reports later of
cancel all appointments for the SAP time
hey captain agent Norman Jayden from the
FBI actually right behind you
hello Alcorn hey isn't it Jaden of
course we didn't hurry do you mind
tagging along we can talk as we walk
yeah my kids if I can I wanted to
introduce myself hey we're getting
started but perhaps I like a DSP no it's
fine
I just have to get to the press
conference we have them every day now
believe me it's not always easy finding
something to tell him fortunately today
we have some news all right
have you met again lieutenant Blake yet
yeah we met this yeah he has his own
methods but he's a good cop I'm sure
you'll get him well together
do you know how to I'm sure we'll get it
on necktie I guess oh do I have to do
this
we frank with you I could have done
without the FBI on this one but the
press are all over us this argh you
really don't know how to do this huh
crept up on us and it's fast becoming a
national concern come on 100 don't we're
in this country but what do you know
this guy is exerting going kissing
Lauer's and origami figures work that
one out then the press get onto it and
we suddenly become the center of the
universe I'm here to arrest a serial no
come on okay respect sir the rest of it
it's none of my business
that's right come on should not be that
difficult of course not I come on is
that you make progress and fast the
press want a perpetrator and we're gonna
have to serve him up on a silver platter
I love silver platters well I'll be a
better profiling than a tying knots well
why do you ask me if I'll manage
like two seconds
what the [ __ ] go see Charlie and she'll
show you to your office now chicken take
a press conference if you're interested
I can [ __ ] hear you have to hear the
political climate around here thank you
sir
welcome to the club Jaden all right
hello that all right I saw a gun I
arrived maybe I should go talk to him
let's talk to DSP as you get Perry's
assistant show me my ass I can't wait to
get to work I guess I gotta talk to the
girl show me my office please
girl Gera sup girl what is going on my
screen is so bad
it keeps flickering on and off it's
really annoying I guess I have to play
with delay collection for [ __ ] that [ __ ]
nice watch oh it's the present we offer
to our new lieutenants if I model each
year for the past 20 years for each
promotion it optimizes everybody's time
and it's the kind of thing that always
goes down well it's kind of a green fund
if you like we're still a few dollars
short I refuse I I don't have any change
problem
maybe next time around probably not ha
ha ha ha ha I actually have a dollar
show me out Harry said you could show me
to my office yes of course follow me
thank you
we're gonna
we're gonna bag we're gonna bang we're
so gonna bang you get back
thank you later beautiful Arthas yes
this is my office that's where I was
told to take you you know where to find
me
fizzes awesome oh come on cheer up we
can make it rather the time to work all
right when it's solved this case sit the
[ __ ] down
Jaden that's right get rid of that even
the phone all right I don't need a phone
they could have [ __ ] cleaned a little
bit what what am i doing why am I doing
this I don't need this job okay I'm just
pushing it why all right it's down and
solve some criminal things where they re
I guess
step one change the office whoo all
right let's do it
I'm filling a filling a little Spacey
today let's go with space wah we're on
Mars but didn't expect that I guess I
don't know where the [ __ ] we are
okay hell yeah
now what you need to check for clues
this all makes sense don't even worry
about it
okay so we have the tracks
let's analyze them your killer car is
probably a Chevrolet Malibu 83 that's a
step forward uh can we have a G analysis
on that no data data goddamn it we're
screwed
well well well well open eight victims
in the last three years all boys aged
between nine and thirteen no signs of
violence the victims disappear from
public places in broad daylight how did
he do that Xenophon bodies found three
to five days later drowned
uh so that means we have five days to
find Jaden oh my god let's take the can
you move please a job or soo sorry I
wish you all an origami in the hand and
orchid on the chest the victims always
been dead for less than six hours when
they were found which means they
remained alive for several days before
being drowned that's not very nice over
3500 people questioned Wow 100 suspects
interrogated ah not a single lead to go
on he's good fun though sorry we need
more clues breath oh no it's happening
must resist masturbating good come on
dude you can do it I know you're at work
and boy here we go again think about
something else wash my face all right
let's do it
get up I need to take some I'm gonna
faint if I resist
don't wait up wait I know I can make it
I know
do it no I can make it exit
[Music]
all right we can do this press this is
actually really important I'm a Titan
everything is totally touched my girls
everything all right I'm glad you cared
so much
all right I'll no want to see no uh I'm
high as [ __ ] all right uh-huh okay
he's hiding his shaky hands I think this
is all the best [ __ ] master cyst
oh shut what are you going Brad oh no no
no no we have to make this we have to
make this I'm serious
all right I'm changing back to the other
screen because I'm getting delay I just
really want to make this
all right
[Music]
it's really [ __ ] hard to control
wash your face bro oh we made it wasn't
too difficult we entered the ladies
restroom then [ __ ] how wait that doesn't
look like a lady
[Music]
oh you know who that is bras see they're
all connected
I mean that they look kind of similar
[Music]
this is lieutenant Blake mr. Marsh could
you please tell him that happened it was
this afternoon
I left the park with my son Sean we
played together for a while and then he
wanted to go on the carousel so I put
him on one of the wooden horses and when
I turned back
Shana disappeared
exactly what time did you arrive at the
park try to remember exactly mr. Mars
every detail can be important Wow I
think it was [ __ ] work this piece of
[ __ ] alright there were five feet
through D I think 5:30 sure what was
your son wearing when he disappeared
he was wearing a coat and a thong it was
brown if I can [ __ ] see it I can't
click because I [ __ ] can't see and a
pair of pants good job on getting that
question wrong her pants was looking
green how could Shawn have disappeared
without you even noticing weren't you
right by the carousel
can't you just uh well I did I I didn't
leave I watched the carousel show
possibly vanished if you're right there
watching the carousel I don't know I I
don't understand you say you took your
son to the park after school but you
didn't report him missing until 8:15 why
did it take you so long to contact the
police I went home and look for him you
stupid [ __ ] I searched I searched the
whole neighborhood for him I thought he
couldn't have gone far
did Shawn have any particular
difficulties mr. Mars anything that
might have caused him to run away
yeah Shawn is a sensitive child our
relationship has been a little difficult
recently
everything okay at school any particular
problems between you and your wife my
wife and I have poor guy who read it for
the last six months but Shawn would not
have gone off without telling his mother
of me all right that's all the questions
I have for now you're free to go mr.
Mars will continue to look for Shawn
overnight we'll contact you if we have
any more questions um dude do you think
the origami Kirk yep
listen your son's probably just run off
and I'll turn up in a couple hours but
what if it is the origami killer well
then we have about four days to find him
alive
done done done [ __ ] love this game
IRAs gonna end this episode here but
lack of payment if you enjoyed subscribe
to come over today and Allisyn exit sir
oh hey Riley
have you breast
you